do you think cassin and will be doing
right now if you didn't die in Rogue one
what would he be doing right now
so it's been six years since we last Saw
Cassian uh what made you come back and
what was it like returning to the role
after all these years it's been an
amazing ride you know uh
I got the chance to to answer all the
questions that the film doesn't answer
you know we meet Cassian enough in Rogue
one uh once he's already committed to
the cause here we're gonna find out what
got him there you know what what needs
to happen in the life of someone in
order to be willing to sacrifice
everything for a cost you know that's
that's uh that's the journey we're gonna
uh discover here and uh it's it's really
nice to be be back with a character I
love so much and not just with the
character but with this family you know
with this team it's people I admire and
and I loved collaborating with and I
just got a chance to do something very
ambitious you know because it's 12
episodes and it's two seasons of 12
episodes we're gonna do 24 episodes of
of a story uh and and uh and that's a
lot of work but uh I would say I I
wouldn't I wouldn't be anywhere else
because I'm working with people I I love
I love watching and and enjoying and and
witnessing their process uh
and we have a story that talks about us
about what people are capable of you
know but this is this is characters that
are as close as as a character in Star
Wars can be to you or me and uh and
that's cool you know there's no there's
no Jedis around there is it's a very
dark times in the galaxy and it's about
the people finding finding or that uh
revolutionary Awakening you know so but
I've seen the first I've seen the first
four episodes and the production of that
people it's it's beautiful it's more
like a film than a series in my opinion
uh what's the difference between working
on a Star Wars film and a Star Wars
series well in this case there is no no
big difference the big difference
between doing a film uh and uh and the
series like the one we are doing is that
uh well
you have the the good side I'm gonna
start with the good part uh the good
part is you you have the time to do four
films therefore you can have so many
layers explore you you can be the what
Star Wars always asks you to do you know
that big scope that Adventure that uh
shun uh that gets everyone excited but
at the same time you can give yourself
permission to go very intimate and and
very personal with characters you can uh
touch on on a more greedy and and
obscure uh tone where we are sometimes a
thriller a spy Thriller and sometimes a
political drama and uh but then we go
back to the big scope and the the
adventure uh you can give yourself that
room you know when you have a long
format like this one uh characters you
don't you can explore many characters
you know this series is called under but
you'll get to meet many other characters
with time and with depth like film
doesn't let you to the sad part is that
you don't have the time you have on
Cinema you know so you have to be ready
you have to execute really fast you have
to know what you want there is no
wondering time you know a clock is
ticking and and you have to move forward
otherwise you would be shooting for five
years
so so but we gladly we're working with a
team that knows what they're doing we
have a rider that uh writes fantastic
material uh
uh and a team of writers that work with
him uh that delivers something amazing
and and Tony has that Tony has a very
complex approach to what he does
so his material is always Rich he's
always juicy you know so unfortunately
this is all the time that I have with
you today but thank you so much I just
want to end with one thing what do you
think Cassian Ando will be doing right
now if you didn't die in robot what he
would he be doing right now he would he
would still be fighting you know because
things are not right he would still be
fighting and wanting change to come
foreign
[Music]